fine it's fine so like i said because
you've heard this yesterday
i hope to zip through this really
quickly so if i gloss over something
then just
and it's still unclear to you then just
stop me that's fine
now recall the in motion so far right
when you've got like a drawing that
demonstrates how something's moving
something like this right even though
it's a two-dimensional diagram
so far in motion it's actually been a
one-dimensional situation
right so you've got something and it's
moving up and down and that's your
displacement
right and your horizontal axis is not
really horizontal
it's actually time progressing right
it's like snapshots are the same thing
going up and down
okay but now we are like really actually
going into two dimensions so x goes back
to its spot
on the horizontal axis and y goes up
there okay
so x is returning back to being a
horizontal theme
and we have to introduce a second
variable okay now therefore
when you're talking about um things in
two dimensions right in two-dimensional
space
you've got a couple of alternatives when
it comes to describing something in
two-dimensional space okay so i want you
to think back to the unit circle
remember that
actually not the unicycle just a circle
because when you're describing a point
on the circle
okay you can describe it in two ways i
mean the obvious way
for you guys is to use cartesian
coordinates right x's and y's okay so
for instance
you might call that say i don't know uh
four two or something like that okay
so that gives you horizontal and
vertical
definition for where it is okay but
that's not the only way
you can also
use polar coordinates right
and coordinates is kind of a funny way
to think about it but the coordinates
just means two things that match up
together
and you've got an angle and you've got
the distance to get there so to be
r in this case right so therefore you've
got exactly the same two ways of
describing
um projectile motion and an object which
is moving through space
okay so here are two definitions right
your cartesian definition
and you've got your polar definition now
i don't always get called this
but i hope you can see the parallel
the um we'll do the polar definition
first right you need two things
you need an angle right angle of
inclination and because we're talking
about
rather than something's position we're
talking about it's
motion okay you're gonna need an angle
and you're gonna need a velocity okay
now probably speaking velocity here
actually might as well be speed
because when we're talking about
projectile motion things aren't going to
go back and forth
they're just going to go and they're
going to they're always actually going
in a forward motion okay
now the cartesian definition is what
happens after
you get the rectangular and you resolve
your velocity do you remember that just
ring your bell not slowly
yes okay good so you've got your x dot
and your y dot
right corresponding to your horizontal
and your vertical
momentum okay now these two definitions
they overlap
they're just like these two overlap okay
you can describe any point in either of
those ways
okay so let's try and review how do you
change between them
um how do you convert
or if you're going from a polar
definition to a cartesian how do you
resolve it okay
so that rectangle again
so let's think about something that's
been propelled upward and maybe you guys
can help me here
suppose we know that it was prepared
let's go with a polar definition yeah
it's held up at an angle of 60 degrees
okay
and let's fire it off and say i don't
know 120 meters a second
right so there's our polar definition
i've got an angle i've got a velocity
how do i go about resolving it
i'm gonna i'm gonna need to relate this
is this is my v
right and this is what you can call
alpha or theta if you like
okay the horizontal sorry the vertical
and the horizontal
bits that i'm after right correspond to
this distance across here
and this distance up here right so it's
just straight trig in
even in right angled triangles right so
with this 60 in place here there's my
90. for example to get
x i've got this is the adjacent side to
the angle and this is the hypotenuse
right
so which trig ratio am i going to use
because right because it's adjacent
hypotenuse so i can say cos 60
is equal to x dot on 120 right
so obviously if we're after the
horizontal velocity let me just move
that over
cos 60 is a half
so there's our horizontal velocity right
and you can recognize from here
right you should have been given that
set of um
standard equations for x dot this is
that 120 comes from the velocity right
so that's v
and this a half comes from the cos 60.
so that's where your v
cos theta comes from okay yeah ringing
bells
do the same thing for your vertical uh
momentum so i've got instead of cars i'm
going to do sine
because that'll give me the opposite
side right so that's y
dot on 120. so exactly the same let's
rearrange this
120 and sine 60 is root down
all right
okay now just pause for a minute root
three right it's about 1.7
thereabouts okay and this is your v sine
theta by the way
so this is 60 times 1.7 this is 60.
so your vertical velocity is more than
50 bigger
than your horizontal velocity does that
make sense does that kind of match up
with what you'd expect
yeah because you know you're firing at a
very high angle okay
what angle would you have to fire it at
for your horizontal and your vertical
velocity to be the same
45 degrees right okay good so
that's fine obviously if you want to go
in the other direction
let me hear another one another one over
here
if what you were given was your
horizontal and vertical velocity okay
let's go and say
5 meters per second there's your x dot
and 12 meters per second there's my y
dot
okay how do i go in reverse well the
things i need are this angle
and this length right so you can get the
length by using
pythagoras okay and that's where this
other important equation comes from
velocity is x dot squared plus y dot
squared
okay so therefore so just take the
square root so what would you get here
well because it's i'd pick nice numbers
so you can get 13 meters per second yes
theta how do i get theta
yeah so i've got opposite and adjacent
right so tan theta
sorry i've already written here that's
going to be y dot on x dot
rise over run okay
so in this case my actual theta would be
10 inverse of whatever that is
okay so you're happy with that as a
review
um you're going to need to have one two
three four
these kinds of equations right you've
got to remember them but they're pretty
simple to be honest
now there's a couple of things i want to
add on to this to make a projectile
motion
this is just for things that are moving
through the air and understanding how do
we
describe how they're moving okay
projectile motion you know
two initial conditions actually two
conditions throughout
about the acceleration of your objects
this is all about velocity right
so do you remember that if something's
just been propelled
and you're not putting any more force
behind it it's not like uh it doesn't
have a rocket attached or anything like
that
um and you're in a place of gravity okay
what are the two
acceleration equations that you get
the acceleration good
good okay now
these are actually your two starting
points every time you start an
uh a projectile motion question okay you
always begin from here and then you
integrate up to get the rest of
you know your bits and pieces and your
actual equations of motion for that
specific
question